well just this month the CDC reports one
in 36 kids have autism spectrum disorder
to address their needs the accelerated
Learning Academy is hosting an open
house Lauren negretti joins us live from
their building near Durango Drive and
Patrick Lane to tell us how they're
helping kids good morning Lauren
good morning their open house is
Saturday tomorrow 11 A.M to 2 p.m anyone
can come on down and it is free to
attend now the school opened up back in
2021 it's for preschoolers through fifth
graders I they're throwing open their
doors now for people to see their
all-inclusive education co-founder
Jennifer Samuel says it's a resource she
would have liked for her own son
to make sure that we added this to our
community for Las Vegas for nevadans as
the first Academy doing include
speech therapy occupational therapy
education adaptive Fitness early
intervention all in one location
and parents shared it's had a big impact
on getting their kids out of their
shells playing more and in some cases
finally talking right now kids are
registered as homeschoolers the academy
is seeking accreditation as a private
school tuition is eighteen thousand
dollars a year they'll actually be
fundraising out here come tomorrow in
order to establish some scholarship
funds for families to attend now I sat
down with some parents who also shared
what a big impact the schools had on
their family their stories coming up in
the next half hour back to you guys just
such an important resource here in the
community we certainly need that thank
you so much Lauren